Bonjour
-Bonjour Monsieur!
Excusez-moi, cette corde elle est bien
pour faire des nœuds?
Elle est assez épaisse,
c'est pour faire quel genre de nœuds?
Ben là
c'est pour un nœud coulant.
Aucun problème.
Et, elle pourrait soutenir
un poids de 70 kilos?
Faites voir le modèle.
Si par exemple la charge
c'était un homme...
seul, ça tiendrait?
Vous pouvez aller
jusqu'à 500 kilos de levage,
y'a pas de souci.
Mais il faut vraiment
faire attention
à fixer ça sur quelque chose
de résistant.
Ce serait pour fixer dans un appart
avec une poutre apparente.
Et puis pas trop de meubles,
parce qu'elle a tout pris.
Ok c'est parfait,
ça devrait tenir.
Super.
Et vous auriez des tabourets,
qu'on pourrait facilement renverser
avec les pieds?
Bien sûr, les tabourets
c'est au fond tout droit là.
Merci.
Et...
si on ajoute
le poids de la culpabilité
d'avoir déçu toute sa famille
et perdu ses proches,
ça tiendra toujours?
(Battements de coeur)
Ben là je sais pas M'sieur,
va falloir essayer.
D'accord.
Ben je vais essayer alors.
Bonne journée!
Non, non, Monsieur attendez!
-Oui?
Le rayon tabouret,
c'est à gauche.